this was the first high-level meeting
between the UN and Taliban since they
retook power in Afghanistan
and the U.N delegation by the
organization's highest ranking woman
deputy secretary General Amina Muhammad
she held talks with acting foreign
affairs minister Amir Khan mutaki
top of the agenda reversing restrictions
on women's access to education and work
a Ministry spokesman posted on Twitter
that they also discussed travel
restrictions on government officials and
financial sanctions imposed by the
International Community
when the Taliban took power in August
2021 Washington froze almost 10 billion
dollars in assets belonging to the
Afghan Central Bank
the economy shrunk by at least 20
percent
the UN says nine of ten households don't
have enough to eat
ngos struggled to help after the Taliban
banned women working with charities
that ban has now been partially lifted
and U.N delegates say they're pleased
with the progress
last month women were banned from
attending University they've also been
banned from attending secondary
education and some government jobs
the U.N delegation will be looking for
progress on this issue too
Laura Khan Al Jazeera